Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number, and
that number is two one nine two.
David P. Here's a really fair question about
COVID hospitalizations and something I said
earlier this week.
Let's take a listen to it.
I welcome these types of confrontations with
the things that I say because they're fair.
Let's listen.
Speaker 6: I question you were just talking
about how high the hospitalization data.
He was saying that even though the hospitalizations
look high, they're saying that not all of
the hospitalizations are because of COVID
like a broken leg and they just have to accept
COVID or something.
And that makes sense.
But I remember in the beginning of the pandemic,
there were a bunch of right wingers making
the same argument to like, Oh, the hospitalizations
are overrated.
You know, they're they're pretending like
it's COVID when the person really died of
this and we were kind of discounting that
as just kind of, you know, they're their same
old shenanigans of just deflecting, you know,
finding any excuse to downplay the severity.
So why is it now something that we're saying?
Like, is there something specific about the
data that is showing us now that's really
the case?
Speaker 1: Yes, that's exactly it.
This is a great question, which is for a long
time, Republicans have been saying they haven't
so much been saying the hospitalization numbers
are exaggerated.
Republicans have been saying the death numbers
are being exaggerated.
And at one point they were saying hospitals
lie and say someone died from COVID to get
more money.
Now we debunked that.
What is true is that if someone is in the
hospital for COVID on average, it's more expensive
to treat them than when someone does not have
COVID.
So it doesn't matter if they die or not.
Medicare reimburses more money if someone
actually is treated for COVID, because on
average, that's more expensive to treat.
The difference is, before there was no data
that pointed to a ton of the people in the
hospital, with COVID being in the hospital
for something else before you had a situation
Speaker 2: where
Speaker 1: almost anything that was elective
or non-emergency was shut down.
The hospitalization rate for the earlier strains
was higher, and there was no data that suggested
many of the people hospitalized right now
with COVID are actually here for something
else.
We now have actual data, including, for example,
from New York City and Akron is so contagious
it is so widespread and it is also asymptomatic
and so many people that in New York City.
Half of those in the hospital with COVID were
not in the hospital because of COVID.
They are not being treated with COVID.
They, incidentally, are positive, but they're
there for something else.
So the reason why we now can say that and
before we couldn't is that the data actually
reflects that.
It's a perfectly fair question.
And that's the answer.
And they're exactly the types of questions
that we should be asking.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
We'll talk about Novak Djokovic facing prison
for breaking isolation while COVID positive.
This guy is just disgusting.
We'll talk about Bernie Sanders plan for everybody
to get N95 masks, not crappy masks.
And we will talk about Infowars and Alex Jones
claims about being barely able to pay the
bills after they brought in $165 million in
three years.
Get access to today's bonus show by signing
up at Join Packman dot com.
You can use the coupon code.
Wow.
Twenty two.
Wow twenty two to get
a discount.
We'll see you
on
the bonus, guys.